hello and welcome to Beth Rigby
interviews where I speak to influential
figures who have something to say about
the world today and how it's changing
this week I'm in conversation with the
actor Liam Neeson
from powerful roles such as Michael
Collins and Oscar Schindler to more
recent action work we reflect on a
career that spanned over six decades
and we'll hear about his upcoming
Thriller Marlow the 100th film he's made
I hear that you are looking for someone
we're all looking for someone I'll pay
you a thousand if you find hands from
there the puzzle has many pieces I don't
know what you're gonna find
I'm going down the rabbit hole I'm not
afraid to take you with me I do like
this thing about not being afraid
we should be
Liam Neeson there on the big screen but
he started his career on stage back home
in Northern Ireland as a time of fear
and uncertainty we'll hear how acting
provided Nissan a Lifeline growing up
during the troubles
[Music]
and hit a message of defiance after the
recent shooting of a police officer in
Omar
did it make you fear that the peace
process was becoming ruptured the
I did think there's a few Cowboys out
there the peace process is here to stay
near this
[Music]
lots more on that issue to come
including some interesting thoughts on
the possibility of seeing a United
Island in his lifetime but I started
with that major milestone in Nissan's
career
Liam we're speaking at you ahead of the
release of Marlow it's your 100th film
you've clocked up more films than you've
been alive the years you've been alive
it's quite something it's a credible
milestone for any actor how does it feel
to hit that number
kind of unbelievable
you told me this a few months ago you
know Marlo that's your 100th film
it says it couldn't be it says yeah it
is
and um
some nights I lie in bed and try and
think of them you know
I get to maybe 75 that's about it
so
there's a few documentaries in there too
tonight isn't it it is an incredible
work rate though
yeah I guess it is look I've been sort
of logging seriously from day one
and uh I sometimes they nip myself
because because of my luck
I'm gonna get into other films later but
just quickly which of your hundred can
you pick a favorite or is that an
impossible question there's a there's a
few
um
and for different reasons you know
Michael Collins I'm I'm still very
attached to at least because it took 12
13 years
for Neil Jordan for to get the money to
make it because there was a war going on
in the north of Ireland you know
um
and Chandler's list too
um not so much for my acting but I
thought Stephen made quite an
extraordinary
film brilliant film really really
extraordinary and uh
the gray I finished one last year called
Thug for a wonderful Norwegian director
Hans bitter moland
whom I'd worked with before
um I think that's going to be a good
film
I'm a Hitman who's suffering from
from a brain disease
the old days it was called been Punchy
you know boxers got
so that was that was interesting to play
you know oh it's incredible I mean it's
incredible but in your latest film you
play the character Philip Marlowe and
the famous detective created by Roman
Chandler and it's a character that's
been played before by some big Hollywood
greats such as Humphrey Bogart
do you look at how other people have
done it while you prepare or do you
not do that I I I've watched I've in
preparation I watched Maybe
certainly more than 10 Noir filmora
movies John Garfield Alan Ladd Mr Bogart
of course Robert Mitchum
Elliott Gould played an extraordinary
one for uh
1973 the long goodbye Robert Altman
movie terrific film so I yeah I watched
them for a bit of inspiration and
you know uh Robert Mitchum played it as
Robert Mitchum and Bogart played it as
bogarten I thought well I'm gonna play
as Liam Neeson why do you raise the
possibility that Peterson is alive
when I so clearly saw him dead someone
may have seen him recently in the street
and where was this
supposedly
I can't tell you
Goodbye Mr Marlow
I'm sorry that it was ultimately
uninteresting to talk to you
but I do like this thing that you have
about not being afraid you should be
I'll see myself out
the fourth film with Irish director Neil
Jordan it's a working relationship
stretches back four decades and it's
seen you in high profile roles such as
Michael Collins the Revolutionary he
fought for Irish Independence what do
you put the success of the partnership
between you and Neil down to
um well I met Neil when we were shooting
John borman's Excalibur
1979 1980 I think it was and um Neil was
commissioned by John to make a
documentary of the making of it you know
so that's my first
uh really kind of got to know Neil and
um
yeah it's been over it's been over 40
years and we have it's lovely me right
it's we have a kind of shorthand
language you know we don't
uh intellectualize a part or a scene you
know I we just have a short-haired
language and we just get on and
I think he's a remarkable actor and a
remarkable writer too
I'm quite a good jazz pianist as well
you know
um we just get on you know I
I get them I think
it gets me gets you and that makes it
work in terms of the writing and the
parts and the way sure we put the films
together yeah yeah I think so Stephen
Ray Steven has made 11 12 films with
Neil you know
um but before I'm we're planning another
one hopefully at the end of this year
about a fictitious escape from Rikers
Island in New York which is an Infamous
prison
in fact it's so Infamous they're going
to knock it down I believe in the next
four or five years
so you've got another project yeah yeah
hopefully it's never stop to you
um going back to Schindler's List which
I I mean it won an Oscar you were six or
seven yeah one best picture and you were
shortlisted weren't you you won an Oscar
nomination for your performance uh I was
nominated yeah yeah yeah that must have
felt great huh it did yeah it did um
I have thoughts about my own performance
and that but
uh but Stephen made an extraordinary
film I thought but you've talked about
it as a life-changing experience that
film it was life-changing in lots of
ways and quite traumatizing as well you
said so yeah you must have lived it a
bit no
um
maybe a couple of scenes maybe a couple
of scenes I felt oh I'm okay on that one
with Rafe and a couple with their
Kingsley you know I thought Rafe was
extraordinary bands of band was
wonderful too
um
but yeah there was a traumatic moment I
may have told you before or told her
your your channel before but uh my first
day we were actually at the gates of
Auschwitz and the world Jewish Congress
did not give Steven Spielberg permission
to shoot in Auschwitz here's the guy
that made Jaws E.T there's no way is he
going to touch a Regal Nail I am in the
gates of Auschwitz to tell a story so
the art Department very cleverly
recreated
the inside of Auschwitz outside
Auschwitz I'd say the gates
I remember that first morning of his
elves baby's so bitterly cold it was
dark it was about 6 A.M
and I was wrapped up in them
big fur coat stuff ready to do my little
scene
I was I'd say the fencing and I was
looking at all the Huts that are still
there you know
and Branco lustig who got arrested me
his dad and I believe one of the British
person he came up and said how you
feeling I said yeah okay yeah a little
bit cold but you know
and we were looking at the Hudson he
pointed to her they said that's the hand
I was in
I said why
yeah that's
five six years of age
I lost it my knees just went you know
just this is real you know
you know
um it was a very
it was traumatic for me it was yeah
I thought oh my God my heart started
bumping you know but I mean that that's
that's an awful story in that it must
that must have been hard to
um
I didn't want to read there's so many
books written on the Holocaust you know
I avoided them because
because in those years this character
may not have known about that stuff you
know
um
and after the film wrapped I I still
read Holocaust literature you know
there's so much but then I I didn't
but that but that film is it still has a
vital message for today doesn't it you
know a time when far-right ideologies
appear to be on the rise once more it's
a very pertinent film absolutely
tells the story
or one of the many stories of the
Holocaust in a way that that is
accessible to people and endures right
so
sure yeah I mean
it's uh Vladimir Putin guys like
uh
evil personified I think I really do
believe that
we all have to be honor
we all have to watch
people like that but Putin is easy
evil
you started your acting career on stage
back home in Northern Ireland and you
performed during the troubles you lived
through Bloody Sunday what was that
experience like
um
it was
I'll tell you I'll be very honest it was
a mixture of
Joy am getting to be to become a
professional actor and to be working at
The Lyric Theater in Belfast and those
days we were doing a play every four
weeks you know
and uh
but there were a couple of nights where
the the theater would get a telephone
call and to be
to beat the bomb
and we'd have to go out onto the street
with the audience
soldiers came out and searched
after maybe an hour or so okay
you can go back in again so we'd go in
and resume the play that happened twice
uh when I was there
so it
it was dangerous but I I guess because
of my age and because I loved what I was
down I was I was just on a bubble I'm
presumably because you grew up
yeah in that atmosphere of violence you
were it was just something you lived
with it we did and there was an Army bar
accident onto the streets too and was
used to hearing gunshots on a Saturday
the troops were practicing on the rifle
range you know
um
yeah when I look back on I think my gosh
and hitchhiking when I was working in
this bottling plant
in my hometown I used to hitchhike up to
Belfast
two three times a week to rush to play
I mean
crazy
but I again I was in a youthful bubble
man I'm gonna be all right you know for
Ulster it's been five years of funerals
this one was for two Protestant Brothers
killed in a week when there were no less
than 10 sectarian murders
on the last Sunday in January Catholic
civil rights marches defied a government
ban on parades and came into violent
conflict with British troops in the
center of Londonderry
[Applause]
the aftermath of a proxy bomb Twisted
untangled metal bearing Testament to the
force of the blast metal flung at speed
becoming shrapnel causing fatal and
serious injury to the dozen or so police
and Soldiers on duty here the iuc said
tonight that no one should underestimate
the seriousness of the current troubles
Northern Ireland was now experiencing
rioting on a scale not seen for many
years
[Music]
foreign
Belfast
Birmingham
Brighton
enniskillen
shankill
gray steel three and a half thousand
people were murdered during the troubles
growing up in Northern Lights like for
many people the troubles
they might not have grown up living
through that time
what was it like living through that
time did you live in fear or did you
just it was just part of your life it
was part of my life
um
I I did get a rude awakening uh January
it's coming from a
physics class in Queens University
and uh I was walking up to the halls of
residents and I've suddenly surrounded
by like 100 students oh
but yeah we're going scarves
what have I done
oh
cocoon my bubble anyway when I got back
to the house of residence I turned on
the news or something and heard about
the Bloody Sunday and dairy you know
I felt ashamed I'll be honest I thought
I have to I have to learn something
about the history of my country here you
know
because I was ignorant you know and did
you go and I did yeah was it a political
Awakening it was a political Awakening
it wasn't many ways you know
and uh
and reading subsequent murders and
Horrors that happened
two miles two and a half miles away from
Queen's University but when I was there
1971 72 you know
saying oh my God
what Good Friday agreement
uh 25 years I was Northern Ireland and
for bitter bitter enemies
to ultimately come together and make an
agreement with the health of America of
course the clintons
it is quite an extraordinary achievement
you know they had talked through the
night in 1998 an unthinkable compromise
hung in the balance
I'm pleased to announce
that the two governments
and the political parties of Northern
Ireland have reached agreement
foreign do you remember that do you
remember where you were when that was
all signed and that event yeah I was uh
it was mainly Aid yeah
um
can I remember I was certainly Living in
America you know but I'd come over to
Ireland we were working on started
shooting Michael Collins I believe
but there was just a feeling in the air
you know
of change
a chance for good and change for good
but you have spoken in the past about
some of the experiences
of growing up in that
tense and violent atmosphere and you've
spoken about you and your three sisters
all suffering
from PTSD from some of these experiences
I guess we still manifest itself for you
um
I don't
think so
um
on time for him for my three sisters and
myself to kind of talk about
a neighbor a neighbor's tragedy
ah
violence commissions against
certain Neighbors in our street and it's
like
um
but but I think we did my sisters and I
both did suffer from PTSD I think yeah
because because you were you were tough
you were catholic you were growing up in
a Protestant yeah but that but it was
um there was no
there was no reflection of that in my
life you know there really wasn't
I had a good school schooling
um
I was very aware of an awesome damn
situation you know
certainly when I came to the 12th of
July and orange marches and stuff like
that but as a kid we joined in them you
know it was it was a fun day you know
um
kind of reminds me actually of dairy
Girls TV show
uh these kids growing up and being
youthful and talking about boys and
girls and the thing the way
teenagers do you know and yet surrounded
by this
this violence
army trucks and bombs going off and
stuff and it's quite a remarkable show
and
my sisters and I were kind of in that
boat too I think I'd have saved because
uh saved
I had no Anderson zoning I knew nothing
about the politics but but I I was an
amateur boxer
that plays at school that that kept me
out of trouble you know
it was your escapism it would just cut
you off the streets and it kept you away
from getting drawn into yeah yeah it
certainly did yeah
that's uh many uh boxing events
tournaments I had I know some of those
kids from Belfast are no longer with us
because they died tragically on the
troubles you know I don't think of three
or four of them you know
but you did I mean that wasn't your life
and you it was my life no you you had
these these two passions and one of them
you've turned into an incredibly
successful career and you you just
talked about the the um Good Friday
agreement and the 25th anniversary and
you know President Biden we think is
going to come it's gonna come over to to
mark this this really important
anniversary but last month the Northern
Ireland police officer John Caldwell was
shot in Omar
um it happened in front of children yes
did that what did you think of it did it
make you fear that the peace process was
become enraptured oh
Ira or whatever you know
you know um
the peace process is here to stay it is
everybody wants it
certainly in the north of Ireland
and
but you always get that don't you you
always get a few Cowboys you know you do
but I do I wonder too whether what you
think about this whether some of the you
know brexit and some of the tensions
around
post-brexit trading in in Northern
Ireland and some of the divisions that
that all caused or brought things to
Bubble Up to the surface again do you do
you ever think sort of UK politicians
our own politicians have been
responsible for stoking divisions
you're opening a big book there you know
what three four prime ministers in the
past three years or something
um
I don't know where to begin with that
one
it's I try and follow what's happening
politically and uh
I'm from the Northern Ireland of course
very proud
to be from there because I think it gave
me a work ethic to Protestants and
calories there's a wonderful thing about
Northern Irish people they do have this
wonderful work ethic you know
but on the world stage when you see
what's happening in Ukraine and stuff
and there's a politician talking about
we have to get our sausages in from
Britain and to Belfast and it's like oh
come on seriously is this where we're at
they're bigger things there's bigger
things but I know the sausages are
important enough
scheme of things and it's being resolved
well yeah and hopefully the
power sharing Arrangement will get going
again installment because it's important
is they have to get back to work yeah
they're representing the people of the
north of Ireland get back to work you're
drawing the salary still
do you I'd move on for this book just
one more thing do you think
I know you've lived in America for a
long time but when you go home
can you imagine Ireland
reuniting the reunification of Ireland
in your lifetime or do you think
um
I think it'll happen do you I think
I think Britain will be pleased
you know they don't have to put 50
billion into the
Northern Ireland ex Jagger every year I
think that's what it costs oh yeah
I think it could happen yeah but you
know everybody has to be appeased you
know the Protestants in the North Island
have a strong voice
I hear them I know where they're coming
from and they have to be you know
inspect it if there's going to be a
United Arnold their voice has to be
heard they have to be represented if
United Ireland comes by it well and you
know symbolically it'd be very big
moment when President Biden comes over I
think the clintons might be very far be
I know when the clintons uh came over it
it changed their lives personally and
politically you know it's such an effect
on them
walking up the Shankle Road Holden eyes
seeing High the people were joyous
that they were being seen
on the world stage
Protestants and Catholics and I was
momentous I know that for a fact from
the clintons have they taught you about
that I spoke to President Bill yeah yeah
um
a number of years ago yeah had a big
effect on them you know
it was cool well it kind of put and put
put the people of Northern Ireland in
the Irish peace process in the heart of
a American presidents and successive
American presidents with President Biden
as well exactly and I forgot to mention
George Mitchell Mitchell Senator who's
really responsible for yeah galvanizing
that peace process you know
um thank you so much for talking to me I
really enjoyed it
[Music]
Liam Neeson there on his career in film
well I hope you enjoyed this week's
conversation as much as I did and if you
scan this QR code on screen now you can
watch all of our interviews online and
all the previous episodes of the show
and if you scan the QR code on screen
now you can listen to the Beth Rigby
interviews podcast each week I take a
look at the highlights of my interviews
and there's some extra bits and pieces
in there too this week we're talking
about the budget that's on the Sky News
app or wherever you get your podcasts
well that's all for today's show thank
you to my guest Liam Neeson and thank
you for watching
foreign
[Music]